[Music]
some rivalries go down in history and
define the games they take place in the
LA Lakers and the Boston Celtics the New
York Yankees and the Boston Red Sox the
Toronto Maple Leafs
and the Montreal Canadiens team solomid
and cloud9
these are the two historically the two
greatest themes in North American LCS
history
c9 vs TSM is our Yankees Red Sox it's
our Lakers Celtics it's the big rivalry
of the North American LCS TSM and c9
have clashed over and over again in
league of legends
their rivalry is at the core of the NA
LCS and every time they go up against
one another
it's the game to watch together these
two powerhouses have made the game more
exciting more interesting and more
popular as far as I know the only na
team that I'm worried about is cloud 9
this is their story
[Applause]
TSM and c9 s rivalry is built on skill
dominance and a mutual animosity between
fans but the story of their rivalry
actually began in a partnership between
the two owners jacket n now the owner
and founder of cloud 9 started his
eSports career as team solomid general
manager while with TSM Jack worked with
Andy Reginald in the team's founder for
nearly two years as the team established
itself as one of MAS best
Sullivan he's Onias from French no one
feels gonna happen they're legendary
catalyst that they will not be stopped
and when the Wild West of early League
of Legends gave way to the relative
order of the nascent na LCS TSM was
there and ready to domina
it's a great bullying it's gonna be out
forever that ghosts our chances gonna
get absolute zero for child though odd
one interrupts if it odd one goes down
now
Reginald take it incredibly now cutting
it in that chowster sneaking oh ha GG
second though he goes down it's walk
total picked up that killed now don't if
try and turn it when you get focused on
original knock my camera can't use it
with the Crescent nuts shadow down
bullying and that's gonna be an ace for
Team solomid no they're gonna pick up
Aaron the team finished first in the
regular season with a 21 and 7 record
and emerged victorious in the finals
with a 3-2 victory over good game
University this is gonna be it for TSM I
think we have our champion
there it is TSM in game 5 looks to be
your North American LCS spring champion
winning the first ever and a playoff
cemented tsm's place in history they
were the best team in North America the
poster boys for what a top tier League
of Legends team should look like and a
team that was supposed to lead the game
into a bright future in the meantime
though Jack was trying to build a
franchise of his own ahead of the first
split in spring 2013 he signed yuzuki
high yen wild turtle and lemonnation as
the first iteration of c9 the team
failed to qualify and were quickly let
go after the loss hi the team's captain
knew they only had one more shot if I
don't follow fire I'll go back to school
and if I do then we'll see where it
takes me the rosters signed with quanta
gaming and brought on balls meteos and
sneaky with hi moving to the mid lane
when we were first qualifying for the
LCS all our practice was going super
well we basically destroyed every single
team and it's not like we wouldn't lose
any game and after winning the summer
promotion tournament the team was
purchased by Jack and
brought back under the c9 banner 5-0 in
the tournament they are in the LPS
cloud9 went 25 and 3 in the regular
season including a 13 game win streak to
end the season cloud9
taking the game home in style 31 to 11
in 37 May's proving once again they are
the number one team in North America and
much like the regular season they
bulldoze their way through the playoffs
taking down Dignitas to 2-0 the best of
one the best of three
cloud9 knows how to play it in front of
a stage and on the stage in front of a
crowd they're able to take it c9 then
faced off against TSM in their first
ever LCS final series and made quick
work of them to the tune of a clean
three oh sweet there's the equalizer
Ollie throws it down it's going to be
the exit they have to walk over at
Iris's in the middle that's exactly
where he wants to be locket of the iron
Solari comes out he's trying to disperse
double-kill coming in for sneaky again
lemonnation picks one up for himself
doing good things for the team doesn't
take anybody but sneaky on the triple
there we go not good for wildturtle
wildturtle gets taken down immediately
how do you engage a fight with the guy
inside your base already TSM getting
taken out it didn't even look like
theirs to begin with it did not hit the
Nexus with their eyes on the Nexus their
eyes on the summer split completely
undefeated
25 and 3 on the split cloud 9 does not
drop a single game in the playoffs the
game was so one-sided that it even
surprised cloud 9
well then we finally beat them on stage
and 2013 we're like oh that was easy
ok the win gave c9 a bye to the 2013
world's bracket stage while TSM had to
play their way out of groups but in the
end neither team went any further than
their seeding with TSM falling out of
groups with a 2/6 record after failing
to be two Korean to you for the third
year in a row Reggie and his team are
heading home early from the world
championship once again here and c9
losing to 2-1 to fnatic fnatic I'm gonna
go through to the semi-finals take you
down the North American champions cloud
9 between the playoff series and the
international performance the stage was
set for what would become a rivalry that
defined na the two teams were
neck-and-neck in the standings
throughout the 2014 spring split with
just two games separating them at a time
before c9 eventually pulled ahead cloud
9 staves off team sola made it one more
time to go three and O in the 4 batches
against them cloud 9 is going to be more
than happy to keep Seoul
place and once again c9 dominated the NA
LCS playoffs will be Game one in 38 and
a half minute for cloud nine are looking
like the best team in north america
right now that is game two now cloud
nine one game away does break splint
title culminating in a brutal 15 in one
final game where they barely gave TSM a
chance to breathe there was no longer
any doubt about it
c9 were amazed powerhouse they came in
from the Challenger scene and took the
LCS by storm
swiftly eliminating whatever hopes TSM
had of the coming n A's first dynasty
and c9 weren't just the first ever
back-to-back champions they were playing
the game in a way no one in the West
ever had as they were mimicking Korean
macro to the best of their abilities and
unleashing it on an unsuspecting region
we watched the Koreans and just you know
what they did because they wanted what
all-stars saying and we think that they
play the best c9 changed the game in
North America and that gave other teams
the motivation they needed to catch up
c9 enter 2014 summer faced with more
determined competition it's now 14 to 8
overall the 10,000 gold lead as they
start taking on the Nexus turrets and a
pretty convincing middle it's a late
game as lmq is gonna take down cloud 9
but they still came out on top here
comes the Nexus 34 minute game cloud 9
gonna take up a couple of more went to
the end of the week and they
heading into the playoffs the North
American LCS and just behind them was a
new and improved TSM who ended the split
in third place GSM looking absolutely in
control this game yes it was 37 minutes
but it was because Yugi had the COG wall
that was keeping so much respect as far
as Lane could be pushed down clean
deciphered with my PSN great way of
bouncing back from Earth who come
playoffs showed that they still had what
it took to hang with the top teams L&Q
still wants into the fight whether the
slowed or not they're trying everything
and they're trying their damndest now
they know they need to turn around the
finisher from Ericsson you can see the
sillies damages still but they shut it
down too early for kills coming up for
Team solomid the inhibitors are down the
Nexus turrets are in the eye the team
solomid and they're gonna solidify a
trip to the World Championship and to
the finals that we will be playing on
Monday for North America what a series
JSF wins the stage was set the former
champions against the defending
champions the two na goliaths were set
to clash once again but this time
TSM gave c9 a cloud ride their first
ever playoff loss
in our second game of the best-of-five
series here the 2014 summer playoff
final we're going to Game three ladies
and gentlemen we're gonna go to a game
five the NA LCS playoff
team solomid takes game for over
not much damage from the shockwave but
the control TSM needs to reassess the
fight boss gets hit up the glacial
fissure on the backside they follow that
into this fight and our coma true bro
pongleton tries to get his own sit down
lap last breath has already been used
coming up with Bertha swagger Naruto
turn on the turn
[Applause]
turtle after all the tensions yes m5 the
fight and wild turtle goes wild right
there on that last fun outplaying cloud9
and carrying chest have the championship
days
American champions it takes a lot to
make a rivalry happen but when it does
it can be magical c9 vs TSM is our
Yankees Red Sox it's our Lakers Celtics
it's the big rivalry of the North
American LCS c9 and TSM are both locked
in a constant war to be the best na
representative at international
tournaments like worlds c9 is still the
best international performer for n a
piece of course by far the best domestic
team of all time after winning the 2014
summer split TSM began to dominate the
na s yes if they were informed they'd be
the first-place team without question
and demolish their opponents in the
players TSM looking to close this game
in under 30 minutes as well they got
better and better throughout this series
one loss followed by three wins and team
solomid if they can close this game out
team solomid in four games heading to
the finals TSM back in the finals yet
again to face who other but cloud 9
turtle now is the focus to depth charge
into anger toss they lock him down with
the passive but he is hopping around way
too much on kalisto turtle the duffel
turtle of all Quadra could he be coming
up with a Penta
he stays on the fountain the quadrakill
once again to come up with Team solomid
pivotal win on the North American spring
split and they will do it once again the
consecutive wins for Team solomid the
Nexus Falls and team solomid
for the 2015 North American League of
Legends Championship Series spring split
champions and if they were not in top
form they be middling all season
teammate with their first upset of the
summer split former first place TSM will
get dropped by teammate and flip the
switch come playoffs 36 minutes on the
clock for possibly the fastest game of
the series turtle is fully shielded up
right now no Nexus turrets they're free
to chose down that's one turtle looking
to go around the Nexus but they say
focus get it down on the priority target
50 gold going into a wild turtle as he
takes it down and team solomid take the
semifinal series to face counter logic
gaming as they take out Team Liquid TSM
holds the single highest number of first
place postseason finishes with a
whopping six trophies while c9 is locked
in a three-way tie for second with to
TSM one 2014 summer there's the trophy
for first place at North America
hoisted high then 2015 spring series
spring split champions then came second
to CLG in both 2015 summer and 2016
spring before returning to first place
from 2016 summer to 2017
[Applause]
[Applause]
TSM cement themselves as the greatest
team North America has ever seen six
championships and ten splits
they have never missed a final they have
never missed world and they are once
again your North American champion
meanwhile c9 were going through their
own set of issues they play second to
TSM twice after their run then had a
long period where they just were very
good at all but somehow they managed to
make miracles happen seventh place in
the regular season two worlds cloud9
makes the run all the way through the
regional qualifier and their last series
is their best one it didn't matter
though at home during the regular season
or the playoffs
TSM always seemed to get the better of
seen on cloud nine winning the first
game rush trying to prevent the sweep
TSM coming back strong though three
consistent games in a row and a bloody
bloody fourth game that they may just
take it on 23 - six thirty minutes into
the game Team solomid take the
quarterfinal match against cloud nine
take for example the 2016 na LCS summer
finals where cloud nine made an
improbable run to finals after a
middling season and despite being down
2-1 to TSM by game four they were
comfortably ahead and ready to take the
series to Game five and then double
lifts maybe impossible we resolved
couple now can they have the follow-up
damage a couple of Suns come in they've
got Gibson and they shut up down with a
1600 damage critical low-medium sort of
American traces white but it's another
look at UGA
Oh
around the fight staying alive so much
patient by this time and he takes over
but see nines postseason stumbles
weren't just from TSM out playing them
sometimes c9 outplayed themselves here
we go there's reading in as well that's
Garrett's been gonna try to keep them
out Redemption downright died that give
it
to get the kills of an outrage
in the fight movie goes down Jensen with
zhonya's and an alt that could have
protected him got deleted effectively
throwing the game for c9
[Applause]
but once again an alts champion cloud
[Applause]
cloud9 fans have become used to seeing
their team lose to TSM in increasingly
improbable circumstances they've
resigned themselves to their fate
they're the perennial underdogs
despite usually coming in with an
incredible roster split after split at
the start when c9 first came in and way
back in 2013 c9 was the best in North
America
then there was kind of the reign of TSM
where 2014 spring was the last time
cloud nine actually won a split in fact
TSM has had other challengers to the N a
crown for two straight splits tsm's
original pre LCS rivals counter logic
gaming dominated the region but clg's
rivalry with TSM is rooted in the past
and their success since then has mostly
been on and off cloud nine on the other
hand have consistently pushed TSM to the
limit but perhaps more importantly
they've gone into several splits with
what looked like one of the best rosters
in the league first there was the
original five balls meteos sneaky and
elimination led by high the first I'll
CS was just I don't know this seemed too
easy but then as time went on it got
harder and harder wha
he definitely wins the LCS not expecting
it to go like that we thought there'd be
more competition but this really wasn't
in the beginning then as the roster
began to falter cloud and I knew they
had to make changes but couldn't get rid
of high without him the team looked
helpless with him they were world-class
now elimination trend on away very low
on Howell
Zeke's Harbinger is on and that's a
couple of kills picked up with the
two-for-one one
huge super Sneaky come through holy cow
cloud9 but eventually they free
themselves from highs influence there
was Danish superstar Jensen wild Korean
jungler rush former world champion
impact X TSM jungler Spence Garen and
most recently a crew of rookies that c9
has proven can stand on the LCS stage
from contracts to licorice to flapper c9
has consistently put together
star-studded rosters that can compete
with the region's best meanwhile TSM
have branded themselves as winners which
means their rosters are often headlined
by the world's best talent here this
will be a win for TSM the great play
special flashes for the coming get
slowed down index that eats most of the
hits he's the first victim of CLG is the
N has respawn he's back in the fight
he's taking my note down
turning may see yes it's got a double
kill link forced away double whoo-hoo
knee goes down now it's gonna be on a
wild turtle they try to get any flower I
should say and it's the triple kill
going forward in the fight do they turn
out for the kill box are fighting a sin
and Mickey look suggests in the bucket
hey Bubba dastan throw is able to get
everybody out fed takes down hoody in an
instant and I thought it's gonna be left
for dead for the October
[Applause]
the thing that's perhaps most notable
about the TSM c9 rivalry is that while
TSM have dominated domestically it's one
of the biggest rivalries in the North
American LCS TSM and c9 have met in the
NA LCS finals more than any other teams
it's been c9 who's performed better on
the international stage when you factor
the world championship into it
that's where cloud 9 has consistently
been doing better than TSM TSM has
attended every World Championship but
one while c9 hasn't missed a Worlds
since their inception c9 have often
looked like the better team at Worlds
despite rarely being the region's
favorites and there's no better
expression of that rivalry than their
clash for international representation
at the end of the 2018 season going into
the season TSM super team of Sven mithy
tonsure and bjergsen looked incredible
on paper but after a week spring split
people were less confident in their
abilities meanwhile cloud 9 benched
their star players in favor of fielding
rookies and despite a weak start to the
split managed to go from 10th place all
the way to playoffs which put them on a
collision course with TSM this is the
old North American like number one
matchup bjergsen versus Jensen that we
were used to the teams traded games back
and forth but it was cloud nine who
pulled ahead in Game four
bring out the silver scripts we're going
to Game five and it was c9 the close to
death must've been against cloud nine
that's a second Jarrett Falls the
responses
seconds it scary to go to clue complete
it
it was c9s first postseason victory over
TSM in four years but it wasn't there
last yeah I mean it felt super good like
the when we meet them in the semis
it was super close because they don't up
taking it to two to one then we had to
bring in golden and spend and that's
where the swoll bros came out and ended
up helping us when that safale super
nice
after taking a loss to Team Liquid in
the finals cloud9 was forced to play in
the regional finals nothing new for them
but it was the first time in years that
team solomid had to play the gauntlet
meaning it was the first time that c9
would ever play TSM for the last spot at
Worlds
he's gonna surely be knocked out on this
one
looking for his fence watch that stinky
he's gonna be routed but he's still
gonna find that kill
it's the ice for cloud 9 t is enforcing
cloud 9 to give us a new look to see if
they want to complete that sweep or if
TSM can reverse their fortunes and win
three straight plow 9 beat a weakened
TSM into the ground earning a trip to
Worlds and denying TSM their trip to the
tournament for the first time ever
yeah we ended up beating them again in
the gauntlet and they like great samurai
super high and once they were there c9
made the most of the opportunity 36
minutes in cloud 9 puts the finishing
touches on the Nexus turrets and the
Nexus will follow cloud 9 takes down T
for the first row let me to try to carry
it can it happen outside the bases door
but Magus for trying their time
cloud9 and their rookie studded roster
showed the world that na was worth
taking seriously ki Jensen and the rest
of the boys in blue went all the way to
the semi-finals further than any na team
has since season one giving c9 fans
plenty of ammo in the endless rivalry
between them and TSM a five-year-old
rivalry nearly as old as the LCS has
finally shifted back to where it began
with a dominant almost mythical c9 and a
downtrodden shaken TSM TSM still leads
their rivalry five to four in postseason
series wins both teams have rebuilt
both teams are coming into the new
season swinging trying to take back
their respective Thrones but only one
can win and when they clash you can be
sure that all of na will be watching
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]